number 1 i'm not a conservative more
libertarian well I swear to God are you
really are a little purse if I'm all for
[__] that's surprising why is it
surprising see you in Seoul the same
[__] everybody else's you know I made a
few cracks on tough crowd years ago oh
and because we're in a left-wing
business I get ya Mussolini but people
who know me even Marin said they're
people who know me I'm nothing you know
I had to get some i didn't had I had to
make people pay attention to me so the
way to go look at that way a little bit
uh but um but I guarantee you and I I'm
all for you should be able to do
whatever the [__] they want if it's not
hurting me yeah that's how I'm to and
the cause we need the government for is
to protect the [__] country
ha
Oh
I mean if you were in Scotland would you
pass 40 minutes before you left 39
minutes for your left is that what you
would do would you not have a podcast
intro done and have to do it while
you're trying to pack 38 minutes before
you had to leave for Scotland that's
just a question I mean I don't know I
don't know I don't know where you were
raised I'm just wondering what what
you're not really wondering ladies and
gentlemen welcome to re-ship very
skeptic tank episode something to 20 to
30 um hell yes stainless steel
retractable ballpoint pens alright I'm
so on today's episode I had here's the
deal i had nick dipaolo odd and i wanted
to talk to you about conservativism nixa
i think pretty much staunch conservative
so I wanted to have them on to find out
you know all the ins and outs of what I
mean to be conservative what do you
actually believe I'm certain things and
break it down because a lot of times
conservatives liberals to get lumped
into the most extreme of their beliefs
and they don't really stand by it like
when I say like you know all Italians
are garbage I don't say that I try to
say Italians are garbage people but when
I messed up its when I say all this or
all that it's like yeah there's test
case like if the homeless person like
some people if they're real conservative
look they're just got to get a job but
if you would break it down and say okay
but I mean some of them some of them
aren't like just lazy some of them
really have mental disabilities and like
their minds aren't all they're they're
kind of crazy they can't just get a job
and if you ask them about that but yeah
yeah sure sure there's some of them are
like that obviously those people need
help and they would say it so I wanted
to get like the full details from nick
de pollo and then i found out during the
podcast he's not really conservative at
all it's more of a libertarian but now
that i think about a conservative
doesn't mean Republican you can be
conservative and and done Democrat right
and liberal and Republican so maybe I
messed up twice anyway fun conversation
so
we ended up just moving into like
talking about political correctness
because that sort of goes hand in hand
with the Liberals because he's sort of
anti-liberal he's anti-liberal he's anti
conservative he's libertarian and the pc
is part of like the liberal agenda the
word agenda is weird anyway so that's it
leaving for Scotland I'll be gone for a
month we gone til november no but when i
do go to australia in october then i
will be gone til november i finally
broke in my backyard yesterday finally
broken the grill used it there was i got
those matches the starters broken but
that's okay the guy told me that but i
forgot because i'm a pothead um yeah
user had soda and in Jay and Christine
and luis gomez over who's [__]
beautiful you guys I got all this off
spray to spray in my backyard because
the bugs get real bad in the middle of
summer no bugs who's [__] great oh my
god we all sat out there nobody had
spots it was August first so i didn't
call i thought i had no spot i thought i
was leaving for all of august i didn't
call in for august so i didn't have any
spots Jay had to leave and come back
Louis had to leave and come back but man
it was great it was great we just sat
out there we grilled we had all sorts of
stuff hot dogs cheese dogs which I
thought were a dog I mean a hot dog
filled with like cheese the way pizza
hut's cheesy crust is filled with cheese
not the case it's infused with cheese so
you don't even see any cheese but then
when you bite into it you taste the
cheese I'm being exposed to all this
different cultural stuff from Jay I he
exposed me to garbage people culture and
I I learned from it um yeah it was great
who's [__] great so glad to have a
backyard I wanted to use it for two
before the summer's gone i was gonna
grill by myself then I invited people oh
yeah paying social is more fun than not
being social
um sad farewell to rowdy roddy piper he
died this week in his uh in his sleep I
heard heart attack which death gets all
those guys heart attack was like the
main thing you could just guess he was a
cool guy he was a real cool guy started
doing comedy I don't know seven eight
years ago he just tried to get into a
lot of those wrestlers are doing
stand-up now cuz they can tell stories
they have a fan base and and Piper was
one of the first ones to do it became
friends with Simone real fast and you
couldn't understand why besides the fact
that someone was a huge wrestling fan
but then you realize how kind a man
rowdy Piper was I mean he was just real
nice to everybody and so respectful of
stand-up he'd be like hey man you
getting pretty good I mean that story
started started coming together he
mostly just told stories took my story
teller show once it was great and he
would always respond the same like oh no
no I'm just this is your world I'm just
I'm just visiting I'm just trying to try
to get better so respectful he's a nice
guy we'd sitting to sit in the main room
by himself and play piano he'd walk in
there is be kind of surreal Rowdy Roddy
Piper playing piano one time probably
one of the coolest things I've ever done
was for Sam tripolis naughty show we had
this whole thing where dana dearmond was
on stage was his guests for the naughty
show [__] I gotta go 30 minutes 33
minutes and the plan was that me as the
amazing racist was going to really get
get mad at dana dearmond because um she
had sex with black people the emerging
races don't like that so I was gonna say
I said all this stuff was pretty fun I
said yeah your grandmother is rolling
around in your grave which is like why
grandmother not my father's rolling
around in his grave Mike oh I assume you
didn't know your father if you're having
sex with black people stuff like that
you know it's fun and then Tripoli the
consummate host and [__] circus
ringleader he's too
Skaar like oh my god this is terrible
this is tell who because they soon as I
had a question he took questions the
audience that's sort of what soon as I
he questions it goes what no wait a
minute is that the amazing racist in the
crowd what just better not be razor than
I was like no I just have questions I
have lived real questions then I would
say all that horrible stuff and then Sam
was I will know and defend this young
woman's honor well no one speak for dana
dearmond and defend her against these
vicious verbal attacks and then the
lights go down and his music comes on
and [__] Piper comes in there and he
said you get up here if you're a man and
you talk to me every stage his little
thing oh it's so much fun there was so
much fun he taught me how to slap him in
the face he was I punched me in the face
so Mike I'm not gonna punch in the face
it was don't worry I won't feel it i'm
not gonna punch her in the face Piper
and I was a fine he talked me into as I
fine I'll slap you or slapping the
better cool he said cool slap me but
don't hit me on the don't hit my ear
that's where it really hurts he taught
me how to like stage wrestle a little
bit and he's like I'm gonna grab you
taught me how to swing at him I didn't
do it perfectly but I did pretty good
I'll make a link to it on this on this
uh on the page um yeah I made a link to
it I mean I I him it taught me how to
wrestle when I swung a time and missed
that's when he took my back and he goes
hey just so you know flail with your
legs it looks better than playing with
your arms looks to still they taught me
all this stuff he taught me how to react
when he's gonna hit me with a belt and
he did hit me with a belt that's it
really goes he goes up to you I can hit
you real hard and you don't react much
alright hit you not so hard but you
gotta sell it by reacting a lot and I
was like option two blues and uh Mandy
[__] grabbed me he played me played
the piano with my head he call that
wrestling improv because it wasn't
planned I didn't plan that the whole
place went crazy the whole place went
crazy started cheering chanting Piper
Piper Piper
damn and then laid up Tripoli was you
know he was like my only regret we
learned all that was not closing with
that but second to the last someone else
had to follow that so anyway Piper Roddy
hot rod rowdy you were cool man you were
cool I didn't know you really really
well but uh he was always cool it's too
bad all right so let's start the episode
this is all about our conservativism I I
am well all right i'll say it later I'm
gonna have Dave Smith stay in my
apartment he's supposed to clean
supposed to all the [__] Louis never did
hang up pictures mount a TV do some
weeding in the back he said he'd do it
yeah Sodor thinks he will big Jay thinks
he won't and so it was willing to bet on
it that he will dave says he will take
says we'll do a right away so that he
has a cool place to live in for a month
and we'll see we'll see we'll see but
anyway regardless it should be fun who
said oh yeah and then if he does if he
does clean it up then we'll know once
and for all who's more respectable
Puerto Ricans or Jews so at worse unless
he destroys my apartment at worse he can
be equal to Puerto Ricans but whatever
anyway the point is guys this is not a
conservative podcast it's about PC and
not being conservative so ladies and
gentlemen Ari Shaffir skeptic tank oh
and by the way my shows at Edinboro
that's where i should say are at the
pleasance dome at the ACE dome with a
pleasant dome I think it's a building in
a building 11 o'clock every night
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
different shows all through the week so
you can come to all four I know a lot of
people just go on vacation for you know
a week or something there come to all
four and tell everybody about it and he
was going to edinboro please help me
fill it up maybe we can do this not
happening in British television should I
gotta go I haven't unpacked yet
[__] why am I so responsible I was on
facebook earlier this is know what I'm
talking about with addiction what time
is it for 20 to 30 to 42 ok 25 minutes
um no I forgot Rosa alright let's just
start oh yeah kind of my shows at
Edinboro this is not happening
storyteller shows me to other comics
I'll tell and [__] sweet stories
maybe get added comics on top of that
cool comics are going to be there Canaan
Michael che tons of British UK my friend
Valdemar from Denmark he's going to do
1p Johansson Glenn will anyway it should
be great so come on down every show will
be different and that is
it yeah see you later goodbye cruel
world oh it's not a cruel world goodbye
cruel country well it's not that cruel
the country the only people is I just
tweeted this but I don't care the only
people who can say goodbye cruel world
are suicidal people and astronauts
alright let's call it Ari Shaffir
skeptic tank episode 2 30 I'm
conservative and been incorrect I think
that's what I called it I'm conservative
and correct with Nick Apollo and get his
CD get his special addictive com get his
special why not he's given he gives a
[__] discount code and Jay and Sodor
have started their serious show so if
you listen to Comedy Central serious I
don't know the call number but they do
the drive time 6 to 8 p.m. monday and
wednesday and they replay the [__] out
of it all week so 6-8 p.m. eastern time
325 western time
or it might be the same time what
sometimes I don't know how that works
ladies and gentlemen that's it aurich
brisket okay
gave me
in a lot
technisat off that's picking [__] up
further great and be wonderful shirt off
feet off um was Mary good mara was great
yeah yeah I haven't known you guys
together a Boston a little bit it's
funny I didn't even know he was there
ever yeah he was he he just got out of
rehab I guess he was out in San
Francisco whatever and I first gig back
yeah he hadn't done comedy a little
while I remember him being nervous and
he was opening for me at a place called
captain dick's end up in a gun quit main
a what a gun quit main it's like a gay
hangout now it's beautiful beach and and
uh yeah he did like 15 minutes and uh
and then we yeah we did all those New
England gigs I don't know he'd been
there and I wish I would have known him
and his using this suit yeah I think he
was just clean when I met him or
cleaning up or trying to her and uh he's
uh he's doing aging he see it suits him
he looks up to him it does sudo yeah he
seems like sort of distinguished yeah
you know it looks good luck with it
would like a cup of coffee and like you
know cardigan on a porch I call him he's
like he's like Dick Cavett now was in
the 70s he's gonna be like the kind of
left-wing show host yeah maybe everyone
is all um air America what is all
political yeah yeah we didn't talk we
didn't bring up politics one really he
probably did that intentionally what
will we have to talk about you know he's
kind of left that all behind though he
doesn't really talk more and and uh yeah
no I think you're right and uh me either
you know people I was never I was never
as political as Mark ever really yeah
you're conservative though huh I'd lane
right I'm not concerned I mean II you
know I'd shoot that guy who killed that
lion you know he would the guy who
killed about the blackrain lion what a
[__] and what it was a deal there was
that was I it was in Africa on but it
wasn't lying was on like a sanctuary I
need to pay somebody like a bra off a
couple of locals you know be glad to
take his money who's me they lowered the
poor [__] lying out with a dead
animal tied to look like a to the Jeep
that's how
lordly lion out out of the sanctuary out
of wherever he was hiding on the
sanctuary I think they killed him on the
sanctuary mighty Lord him i don't know
technically i listened to two different
radio shows in a way in here one guy
said that's illegal you can't kill
honest on a sanctuary that's illegal and
and and the other show the guy made it
sound like they're lying wasn't he was
lured off the probably that I don't know
address we could do it but either way
whatever [__] this is like the only
black man line in existence yeah I mean
13 years old and and uh but I'm also
against people I was kidding i said i'd
kill they got ya the people you know you
want to shoot this guy and [__] I'm a
good Michael Vick man Michael Vick yeah
I'd string them up and do it he did
those dogs so well that's not the
punishment for that crime ya know
exactly already have a punishment and
it's years in prison and there's a
reason you know there's a reason yes it
is you know horrible to kill innocent
dogs but it's still a dog yeah and it
also lose your freedom for three years
is not easy it's not like a walk in the
park know exactly ya he [__] paid his
dues yeah and uh but this this guy's
never gonna be a dentist again he'll be
like uh so he's still flossing twice a
day like i told ya i am you still
[__] shooting innocent animals you
[__] ass rents in the sink I'm not
gonna put my head me a lop it off I feel
like that's the guy's not even gonna
feel it all the negative reviews never
the links to a ridah why Frankie has no
feelings is good cuz he shot the line
yet words like he's not on Facebook and
I was like what are you gonna do i paid
the guy had plenty of money I paid a 50
grand you thinking on how busy grand
lying around minnesota really yeah it's
not like a [__] zillionaire oh I
pictured him like he's the most hated
man right now in the earth and again
nobody's really up in arms about [__]
Planned Parenthood chopped up babies
like old Toyotas and selling the parts
yeah I did the [__] out we are really
our equilibrium is off and i'm not a big
pro-life guy even I'm just saying you
didn't hear people freaking out you know
when they're doing that I heard that
lady everything in that expose you saw
that expose would check with that lady
from Planned Parenthood who's Cecil with
any videotaped her yeah she wasn't
selling that [__] for
was just like a four hour oh there's a
lot more films coming oh yeah oh yeah
it's like locally to Planned Parenthood
huh it's like WikiLeaks replying parent
yeah I'm just gonna keep whipping about
yeah guys got like 12 more films how you
think that was something you think
that's the end of it just wait exactly
you'd seen nothing yet even so I mean
they're trying to say we're not making
money doing by the full of [__]
shabby come on that's uh again i'm not a
big i'm not a big pro-life guy look I
don't be a hypocrite are you pro-life
I'm I'm anti-choice [__] anteela I'm
not anti-choice because I'd be a
hypocrite because when I was young I was
glad there's a couple planned
parenthood's around yeah I got a few
girl so I'd be a hypocrite to be totally
but this is just come on I mean wait
wait hold on back up who'd you get
pregnant I nobody no nobody are well
obviously but I was the story couple
[__] girls yeah man it is so
frightening that that few weeks before
they decide to make the right decisions
Oh writing give a few weeks I game two
seconds I was right over the house i had
my chokehold said i'll decide this for
you know see those cellar stairs uh no
so uh yeah no i'm not a that's i know
that's the perception of my just right
wing abou but with that I was always
fair I see homeless people laying in the
street new york i go that guy would have
been better off a border I know that
sounds cruel but that's what that is
it's an unwanted babies these people
laying in their own [__] they're like
lost souls what do you think the answer
is like homelessness um I mean how are
you party homes mumal Detroit I was
empty home oh I don't know according to
you know de Blasio in DeBlasio if I can
Obama they'll be you know building how
[__] in a low-income housing in my
neighborhood up in Westchester that's
this solution really not an air
neighborhoods but uh what's this so I I
don't know a lot of a mentally ill I
think he got to go case by case you find
out if they get a screw loose she got to
put him somewhere really see most
conservatives don't think that way most
Muslim like just get a job and be done
with it but it's like that's not how
most conservative thing and I really not
i'm not a conservative more libertarian
well
way to go are you really or a little
curious if I'm all for [__] that's
surprising why is it surprising since
you haven't sold the same [__] everybody
else's you know I made a few cracks on
tough crowd years ago oh and because
we're in a left-wing business I get ya
Mussolini but people who know me even
Marin said that people who know me I'm
nothing you know I had to get some I
didn't hey I had to make people pay
attention to me so the way to go look at
that way a little bit uh but um but I
guarantee you and I I'm all for you
should be able to do whatever the [__]
they want if it's not hurting me yeah
that's how I'm to and the cause we need
to government for us to protect the
[__] country the military yeah that's
what I want I want to talk about
military too huh protect the country
doesn't mean attacking everybody we're
not attacking everybody there's so many
play we're in Yemen ma'am why is that
ywain Yemen I don't know I don't little
something call 911 what's out of the
oven that's what do you [__] kidding
me i do it is it's all tied together
course we're in Yemen the foot hole for
[__] people want to lop you head off
I know you want to believe that but
they're never gonna get here they're
really in Yemen there look at village
you're never gonna get another good huh
they're just gotta go that to the
[__] San Francisco parents who lost a
daughter and that wasn't a terrorist
that was just a [__] illegal have
been deported eight times closer now now
you make me smile like a real right wing
what do you think I'm gonna get here
anybody can get here that's the point I
want to take a plane over here to shoot
a bunch of you don't have to take a
plane actually figured out this week
anymore they can take a plane your life
just get right in you're right it's too
easy wait what was the one in San
Francisco well the illegal immigrant
shot that girl walking on the
Embarcadero with her dad yeah on a
bright sunny day you didn't hear about
that no what was he how much will you
smoke it was re all of it man what was
he perfect answer everything he had been
deported like seven times was he mexican
yeah okay just nice sunny day shoots a
[__] beautiful young woman who were
to the catcher what Lisa over nothing he
said he's trying to shoot at he's sorry
one of those seals and they'll walk in
the water and shawna shoot a seal that's
what he said but the point is he'd been
deported seven times the point is you
should been [__] back in his own
country in jail yeah but I you
hero in office sanctuary cities you for
that this differs in Yemen deported
people is that that I just said that my
point was it's easy to get this kind of
weather you're you're an illegal in
Mexico or [__] psycho from Yemen
don't act like on border security he's
[__] by the way i did i did a
corporate for border control in Vegas
once you did yeah how'd they pick you
they saw me in san diego at lecom
restore and what were you saying that
made him say we they said they liked me
oh and those amazing race's videos where
I pick up the Mexicans and taken to i ns
I didn't see what what Oh nicked Apollo
you would love that amazing one raising
racist mexican p by the way um i know
but your you have a dark sense of humor
I very loose I do have a doc said
Schumer about Chile but ya know I was a
home depot and I picked up a bunch of
Labor's to fix my deck and I drove them
to an AI NS building a fixture deck yeah
that was a that I thought they were
doctors ism um it and this was on what I
was just on the web you see on the web I
guess I'm gonna have a google but yeah
I'm an re severe famine I told you that
I [__] seriously I see it the
standard I laugh my ball like this guy's
get his own [__] way looking at [__]
and by the way you guys uh well you
probably know is he's got a mohawk I do
I'm thinking dying a blue today it goes
away in a week I can see the look like
autumn that if it's the neighborhood is
this alphabet city this is it is right
yeah the heart of it I could get lost in
something called alphabet city so stupid
I am did you like what what's but
where's be there were seated what comes
after today is it the area no I uh I
[__] I could have parked three feet
from here but there was a big box truck
blocking the sign I couldn't see the
sign where there was no parking another
so I you know I end up going on
fourteenth Street oh really over four
cents a min and a half around the corner
but the point is I could've park to feed
from here it's the worst when you come
back and see a spot that's open that you
could have parked out don't feel like I
should go back and get my car I do a bit
about that trying to park in new york i
got you about you circling the block and
you finally for 20 minutes and now you
see a spot up you have your eye on that
one spot but you're at a red light and
watch somebody else pulling into that
spots like watching somebody [__] your
girlfriend
yeah he'll never fit in there it's a
parking cuckold no no I hate this and
they're like yeah take it look at what
I'm doing very painful yeah this is
ari's in a new apartment folks are you
think I won't give away the address but
I'll tell you it's a [__] like it you
get the exposed brick yeah and he's got
like dry sausage hanging from his
cabinet like a good my dad gave me a
telephone we got to talk about it and I
was like how much I like it when I was a
cat's as I bought water and then I went
to visit home and I got you two of them
so now is that sausage us what is it
salami rice hearts alone I like your old
man yeah he's got three three sticks of
dried salami hanging from his cabinet
that's New York you won't see that in LA
no I like the kitchens here that are so
like packed full of stuff there's no
room for anything things are hanging up
I got to use that above space what's
what's with the trophies up there oh
that's my trophy for one was to the
roast battle I'd be big J the Rose
battle at New York Comedy first did you
really yeah that's the one on the left
and then the one the right is for a
basketball comedy league in LA I won a
best comic worst player no [__] yeah
that's actually what you should if
you're a comic that would be the perfect
yeah I was like mmm you know what I be
nosing like a jock know it's wrong
business finish remember the first I
mean bet yes in brooks at your prom i
took you here freshman year you had a
nice each dress something off the
shoulder and I was in a blue tux it was
in Boston you were talking again you got
so bad of it yeah eyeglasses that in a
cardigan and um do don't we ahahaha yeah
I [__] wanted to tell you that night I
made the mistake of Miss wording like my
point why did you bring that up though
this is [__] remember that this is a
high said to Rogan I'm gonna [__]
punch your friend in the head you know
that [__] guy I was what did you say
to me the name PA said we're in boss I
say all people from Boston are [__]
jocks or stuff like that analyze you
took a purse like I met meatheads I've
had some people just want to like fight
but you took is like a broken said later
like he played football bet it's a good
as an insult like oh I didn't
in that sorry I would never if you
didn't just say that I would have never
known that was you as I met you one
later or that year later years later
right could see the look in your eyes
like who the [__] is this [__] like
this year because I know you were young
car was his cocky [__] and I was
wearing a cardigan and glasses then I
always got misconstrued for a big old
comic that's why that's probably why I
wanted to kill you yeah like oh sorry we
can't all be Janeane Garofalo I've been
taking that inside the ground like I
don't understand that that's not my hero
I can't [__] believe that you haven't
brought it up since I was scared too i
was like i don't today i was like let's
let's foster the relationship but that's
like a good example of life of you know
not knowing somebody and yeah and then
learning more bottom yeah oh yeah yeah I
had one of those texts phones or flip
text phone yeah she did I was in there
cuz I don't know you and Roberto
catching up I was like I don't know I'm
what am I gonna do join in the
conversation but in was young comic
believe the many you said that I got
angry about that night made me focus I
didn't mean jock seven there's a lot of
meatheads in Boston what kind of
generalization is that I sauce in the
liberal walking down everyone drinks and
fights that's what I mean don't you like
that about Boston I mean as opposed to
what here where they [__] do drugs
and stab each other you're right though
Boston is like the Old West I remember
Dave Attell coming back from a road trip
road trip he did it weekend up in Boston
at faneuil hall and I might be had
coming back and this has to be 10 12
years ago and him saying to me he goes
it's [__] like he goes it's like 1970
over there because people come stumbling
out at two in the morning he goes I saw
like he said literally five fist fights
in faneuil hall yeah all around us I
said somebody the face full of blood
nose down face man about a shirt all
bloody yeah and then he's like smiling
goes let's go get pizza yeah what is
this place I'll tell you what it's just
all about irish place that's a lot of
[__] it's still very irish and they
like to get rowdy I like that and and
and yeah you're right what's called pj
clarke's or something in faneuil i used
to [__] go in there and
I'd have my dukes up on the [__] way
out always what happens is by it would
be a point back when I hung on fan
jahaan the 80s packet will be always a
pack of Irish kids there who would shot
drinking it four in the afternoon and
then come yet did they give last call in
Boston like 1230 really yeah to get rid
of the problem no that's just how it was
Boston's you know they have these blue
laws you couldn't buy booze on Sunday
but what happens in faneuil hall last
call packs of Irish kids would stumble
out of [__] boss you know aight irish
drunk guy who didn't couldn't get laid
some girls just blew my so they stop
bumping into people and slapping your
[__] sausage sandwich other you and
not desirable I mean as though you know
[__] bunch of Italian kids from
revere tu laga bonds yeah yeah it's when
you kick in very at the same time that
they're all rowdy and out in the street
at the same time not jelly is switched
because there were 20 fights they switch
till four o'clock they let it go to form
yeah so now I'm gonna hire didn't leave
one at a time they don't feel like is
that everybody I gotta shoot five shots
real quick well last time I checked
Austrade didn't have a giant Irish
population yeah that's good point you're
not good for you gonna you're gonna keep
a bar open before Irish kids ain't
leavin top floor is Boston racist I've
been heard it's been called like the
most racist I know your stereotypes well
that's where like that but Bill Russell
would say that Barry Bonds would say
that I know in my you know my question
that would be what is Detroit Rice's but
they were saying Boston is more the
Detroit racist I want to know I don't
hear that huh I don't hear about that
big races yeah you're not even getting
that cuz you would you wouldn't even
assume it i'm talking about black racism
you think [__] you see I'm saying
yeah in your mind racism can only come
from I people which is silly because
black people d'être would stab you
quicker than any [__] white
neighborhood would stab a black guy what
yeah yeah you're gonna walk down the
worst neighborhood in Detroit get two in
the morning know about to go detroit at
all no you're not pissed it [__] cut
your throat you know why cause you're
white yeah but no it's also just cuz
it's [__] poor and everything it's
like you pass it out on ego why don't
you get give that break to [__] a white
people you swim there grace well here's
what Buster because in New York South
Boston is a racist neighborhood right
that's the reputation yeah well yeah
that's the presentation who do you think
lives a rich people it's poor white
people but when you you want a couple at
people
ring on economics that's where the
violence comes from but white people
just hate black people it's such
nonsense i would say i would say Detroit
is the most racist city just because you
[__] a white person get his throat cut
quicker than a black person against Roca
New York anywhere well New York's Nava
is it so intermingled ok Baz dagger a
Boston when's the last time anything bad
or certain towns though certain areas
like this is a white area this is the
black area yes that goes to every city
in the country that I've been to not
here huh not here not New York New York
is different now every building has them
really so you go to East New York
tonight you'd be fine which one is New
York East New York is Manhattan no East
New York it's called again there's a
movie thank you for bringing this is it
you gonna watch the documentary then
you'll see it it's called and I've been
plugging this and you're gonna it's
called the 75 the 75 yeah it's about the
75th precinct right that's his new york
yeah and it's about it's a true this is
a documentary about two cops guy named
Michael Dowd yeah who dis out i remember
has now yeah you probably read an
excerpt about it in the post the movies
out now the documentary re if you don't
see a [__] movie pleased about that
it's about the rogue cop who [__]
good just a bad cop who get hooked up
with Dominican drug gang oh really but
you know protected them getting paid off
[__] shaking down other drug gang
really dude if this is back in the late
70s early 80s there's a crack epidemic
in East New York would have literally a
thousand Bert is a [__] year just in
East New York I mean just and this guy
this cop and he's a guy like you and I
just a ballsy guy who saw the world
differently he's like [__] these rows
I'm playing by these rules I'm just
gonna make money off this dude you gotta
watch or listen to this I'm what I'm
some i'm outside Marin's hotel waiting
to go in yeah i checked my tweets i was
talking about the the 75 movie on my
podcast this week one of the choices
from Michael Dowd the car he goes my
son's a big fan of you wow really he
goes like lied you like the movie you
should get him on I'm gone up yeah I'm
gonna when I go I'm gonna [__] tweet
him back you know I tweeted him back I
said oh yeah
I want to get him on my show I'm afraid
to have up my house though consider
credit a [__] do what would you do if
you could be a crook he's not a god
anymore but what would you do what would
you abuse I do what he did what look the
other way stuff no I wouldn't I wouldn't
be a crooked cop I'm a straight arrow
imac wanting guy like it would be a
crooked cop where would your crookedness
come where would it come what do you
mean I be titty bars every night taking
their money [__] them yeah how about
this how about we don't charge my cell
like a conservative to you I'm a
libertarian I'm not very loved it yeah
I'm a libertarian too but see that would
not be a good libertarian mochas then
you hurting other people right but I you
you have to watch this movie dude you
are gonna tear it up a free market like
well if you want to pay me to do this
then Oh then I'll do it they want to say
a market no that's just well no you make
a point I see what you're saying if the
drug dealer wants to pay you to watch
your [__] and love you know is an open
market well I'm off only problem drugs
is a dirty business because it does
wrote a lot of lives I think don't you
feel like they should consider just
making it illegal and saying we gotta
get rid of this and enforce it they
should have some sort of education about
her or reap or rehabilitation should be
more accessible than arrests especially
how many rehabs do you want I heard
that's a whole industry too but I mean
you know people are booze that get too
caught up on booze and they uh they need
just help that's all they just need help
you know I don't know there are people
who need sexually argument comes up but
people don't people don't die / booze
every day like I do but if he likes if I
have friends that were into coke I
didn't The Comedy Store didn't really
have coke people we had weird pot yeah
pot and booze but if some of my friends
got in the coke and then I could have
gotten into it it could have been like
you know peer pressure yeah seven cool
comics like come on all right just take
so it's fine i'm like oh so what's your
point so I don't we need help I would
need a hand up not a [__] place in
prison and that's also i think is a big
myth about the throng people in prison
for doing drugs you know like so not
just dealer may be right there are
people and I know there's a dispute I'm
not going to get it cuz they were good
bore but
disputes you know the amount of crack if
you get busted powder as opposed to
crack and how the drug laws are unfair
to black people and I'm sure there's
some legitimate points there but a lot
of its being over exaggerated if you
read into it drugs and [__] you know
you I may be trying to people he was
arrested for just possession people are
saying people are saying I know and
that's what the people are saying is you
no one's barging down your door to sit
to look in your drawers know exactly but
but but they try to people trying to say
that drug dealing is not a violent
offense yeah which is the most stoop to
me it's a stupid thing I've ever heard
it leads to fun just because you have a
dealer yeah yeah like people don't get
killed every day of a drug money in G
it's the dirtiest business ever just
because you yourself hasn't killed
anybody you see I'm say you're provide
you a ting the violence yeah but the
problem is they throw in drug dealers
who weren't violent all the throat of
prison and pretty much give him a
seven-year training program how to be
violent and they are cool now go join
the world but they are being violent
when they're selling drugs in my opinion
it leads to fashion square park at
Washington Square Park those guys what
the guys that just got a jail playing
chess yeah the guys that sell drugs out
there it was it like ma'am okay I mean I
don't you think they should be allowed
to sell without any really i mean what
do you want the government to take their
cut off it know what sells drugs on a
good thing all right yeah yeah I'm just
saying that I violent but yeah I saw you
don't know that I should I 10 out of 10
of them have records I guarantee ya it
but even if they aren't the they're
ruining kids lives and and it rolled
leads to [__] roadie think complete
but illegal doesn't work it's not gone
just cuz legal doesn't work so it's like
what do you regulate it and say you can
sell this but no one no III don't know
the ante look I know Amsterdam's tried
it and that places a hellhole it's gone
to hell I heard really thought I heard
is a dirty place now I don't know a red
laser you know more about it too may
have been to Amsterdam the red light
district isn't bad but they keep it one
place yeah so it sort of works because
no one and am Sam goes the red light
district no it's like a tourist spot but
it's near the airport and it's just like
regular citizens like
I heard of seven years ago as era yeah
but-but-but aids when they made you know
you know they're handing out clean
needles they did all that [__] over
there and really yeah the one while they
age has gone on everything it's a this
crime has gone up over there this is
what I've been reading but then again
i'm sure you can read a publication
whether to say the opposite I don't know
like Hoover they do the safe shoot up
spots you ever see those safe shoot up
spot weather like it's all facing street
it's a closed only shoot up yeah but
they'll just come in here and do it tell
us what you're taking if you overdose
well we'll get through though that's
great how does that help a person I mean
you're inviting them to [__] can we
agree that [__] doing drugs and if
your drug addict is a bad thing yeah but
the way I know you gonna say well it's
your choice right does he look at that
well is that horrible The Fountainhead
yeah it's the most amazing book I've
ever read I'm halfway through it uh you
know I can't believe I haven't read it
yet it's well i shat on her for like
years and r and I'm rant to be like [__]
her just based on what other people told
me yeah and I and because of my politics
I've heard nothing my great [__] about
oh really what is she what is she what's
her politics I don't know she's like a
no I thought she was like a [__]
pro-capitalist isn't she like really
free market that crazy yeah I get
anything go get any of that [__] from
this I heard later in life she got kind
of crazy and started believing her hive
like innocent no but this is like early
kid acid were all right before that it's
the most about about what's it about ok
it's about two architects yeah one is a
[__] sellout and one's an artist and
the sellout is like he's still good he's
good but he's just in it for the money
and the people giving him cash for ya so
its Fame ok critics and the other one
it's like I don't give a [__] about any
of that I'm here to build beautiful
buildings and everyone else copies the
Romans and the Greeks and yeah there's
no [__] that and he's in this modernist
view and people threw him out of
architecture school because it's too
like crazy yeah okay I'm done learning
from you guys anyway I already learned
everything I could goodbye I'm work on a
rock quarry until he gets work as an
architect because he wants to know what
where the [__] stone I'm already
hooked dude it's amazing and about not
learning critiques there's a I'd like if
you remember the characters names
because Barry cats you know Mary war
Barry I was in a dispute with Barry and
he compared me to one of its Howard
worker Peter Keating or a to e but he's
like the writers compare me to the guy
who would ironically and again my
marriages been destroyed but to me well
in Barry's eyes I'm the guy who doesn't
give a [__] about the money just cares
about the art yeah your hard work I
actually said however yeah yeah just
fine cuz they destroy him you think I'm
like just like Reich when pro and that
funny barry sees me is the [__]
period that's the guy who doesn't give a
[__] so crazy yeah you guys had even
come around big my folks i'm not that
easy to figure out don't face you should
unclip some tough crowd right made some
wild generalizations back clips i
watched every episode that's actually a
good point but yeah i'm not as simple a
do this is passive hear that it's it's
this written out 1940 1920 whatever it
is yeah it's all about how once one
headline it's all the blog [__] now once
one headline comes out everyone else
will write articles about that headline
without even reading I just listen to
the Jerry Seinfeld interview that
they're [__] on him for about yeah
and the Kindler to the state of the
industry address on him and all you were
right it was like you know what I never
actually heard the interview and me
Rebecca trenches looked at all right and
we're like oh he's not talking about
colleges right the guy says and up but
I'm going off headlines and I know
better tomato the guy says what's the
state of the of the you know of the the
atmosphere and I with political
correctness and then he goes on his own
the guy goes i know chris rock and one
other person won't do colleges and so he
briefly says yeah colleges i know that
some of them were tough or and then
answer the first question the state of
political correct right that's when he
talks about his daughter and stuff I'm
just let some some guy write a headline
in like yeah [__] him no you're right
ahead like and carry it but but I did I
mean I did hear him say himself there
you know they got offended and
everything and then which was enough
room yeah which I mean because now I
stayed on stage like I was at the stand
the other night and I do a joke and it
gets a moan because it's too off-color
and I go I'm sorry I go you you guys are
the [__] that Jerry cybele's too
edgy for a
but that's what it is I think it's true
where it's like you gotta go no no I'm
just checking okay tell me what but I
think it's true where people hear the
word sexist or race or anything I go
whoa whoa whoa yes I hung up on the
words I thought the context I have a
joke that has its talking about me doing
something but it's it's requires seeing
some Down syndrome children playing
bowling in my bowling yeah yeah and as
soon as I say there's some Down syndrome
kids some guys guys guys this is not I'm
not making fun of them stop and people
like laughs ago okay cuz just you hear
about it go no no I know I live in that
world every premise that comes out of my
mouth the people are going out Oh
where's he going with is what are you
writing down I'm gonna read that pet
this passage from The Fountainhead the
in the epilogue in the outro I write
down little notes good move yeah thanks
so much don't do that let's come as a
garbage and they're failing out I notice
your uh your podcast is always up there
I check on you know I still trail I
tones I was like I check the ratings you
told me that make yourself nuts right so
but Howard work would never check the
ratings however or doesn't care let us
say I always tell good people say I
always am I'm not him I know I can
Donald Trump no one's that far as a
purist but I want to be like him in
moments I see I'm gonna read this stuff
you should I mean it's a novel not a
book I know what it normally really it's
just funny uh what am I reading right
now what did i just read i read call in
queens book really I heard that's really
good it's so goddamn funny to him going
to the block gonna see it sunday where
is it at the cherry lane I'm always
plugging his [__] cherry lane theatre
okay go get my album another senseless
killing still available at Nick tip com
use the radio code Nick get three bucks
at night and it's doing what's up I went
out LA last week I went to do Rogan I
did corolla I did Fitzsimmons I did dama
rare but Simmons is great Herrera's
final oh that's right yeah yeah and I
just didn't air in an hour ago i'm doing
you and you know what [__] soon as
like by the time i got home it was back
in the [__] top push back up another
sense is killing it's doing folks if you
like why I mean it's you you love it
here's the deal Nick DiPaolo is a
professional comic thank you and you
know what that's best compliment you can
pay him people don't understand the like
how's that guy this kids good it's like
you can't replace 25 years of experience
even if you don't exactly i don't care
what you thought even the people like
margaret cho i know some people are
gonna like her I'm like that was 20
years ago and she's put in five times
more work than you right so it's like I
don't care how bad you are you're gonna
get good when you practice for 25-30
years you're you know and it's funny
yeah somebody said that was in Ventura
when I went out to LA I did all the
podcast a lot on my own time just to
defray the sum of the cost i did Ventura
Harbor comedy club up in mentor yeah and
some guy said to me this guy he goes
you're a [__] trooper oh man I do
like an hour five minutes standing on my
lawyer just the landing on my head yeah
cuz it's almost not if the funnies in
you yeah you know I mean if it's in your
DNA what it's all technique you know the
first time you got to get angry on stage
like oh I didn't do that right I don't
how to do that and yeah well that's what
my point you you the six once you learn
technique after 28 years of you know of
having a presence up there and being a
little unpredictable which i think is
key and then didn't [__] if you got
the funny in your blood you put all that
[__] but these are the nights were you
know is like wow it to be doing it for
two weeks he was highness cuz it's not a
science is that's a work every night I
know what maybe I'll try this like wrong
it's like bass all players like I gotta
cross over that Iverson's like well just
take it like damn its but it is that
exactly it doesn't work every night you
know and you try to tell people that
wrote obviously came in the league and
make Jordan look like a [__] fool
yeah that was like what that's Jordan
and he's still in his prime yeah yeah
yeah so let me get some of your politics
then as a libertarian I want to get some
of this cops how do you feel about them
and and the whole the idea now that
black lives matter and all that [__] and
the cops are racist there's a real
thought of that am I wrong there's a
real one thought of cops are all racists
well yeah that's the perception that
that's put out there by the [__] libs
mainstream media and they've been
playing with fire for years I remember
being in my 30
is going what are they trying to start a
race war just the way they selectively
choose stories where it's a white cop
involved with a black the media just
wants to sell papers and it's dangerous
it's there and it's taken fruition
though but I'm sorry but the the [__]
Ferguson thing yeah that they were wrong
on that they prejudge that that kid had
his hands up bababa [__] totally
wrong on that Baltimore they [__]
they did that I Trayvon Martin they try
to draw conclusions and paint all these
guys you think cops get up every day
they gotta do a job you get you can
agree in this with it they get a risk
their lives basic everyday yeah really
think white cops can go I'm gonna kill a
black cost is a few bad ones out there
that time time to watch his documentary
all right it wasn't really about race
was about drug but he was a dirty cop
right yeah so watch this of course is
bad apples well you remember the UH
Rodney King beatings in the video you
cut off the first seven minutes oh that
boys and that set a minute showed him
fighting to a standstill with those
three cops I know then they just show
him beating him and people see that you
see the moving image and you're like I
mean I'm not immune to rather like
that's awful what they doing all they
show ever that's all even the black the
white [__] kneeling on the black girls
back the girl in the bikini huh did you
see all the people around you don't know
who has what I don't give us [__]
shoes 11 do what the cop [__] says and
I'm not saying it but but the numbers
don't lie cops literally have it's
something like tens of millions of
interactions a year would civilian yeah
it's it's like it's in the tens of so of
course some of those are gonna turn
violent here there and it's gonna go
wrong the point is mostly just super-fun
fulham go wrong re that that's point
zero zero zero one percent that go wrong
hardly an epidemic that's my point it's
the media selectively chooses these
stories and if you do that and only show
the white the cops being bad people are
the median so powerful yeah it is it's
what they realize like we can affect
people's they I know I the Fox News or I
don't know I don't watch those the Fox
News or the other one I'm SMBC they said
we want sixty-five percent of our
stories being pro war and thirty-five
percent being anti war and that way
we'll get our listenership to eventually
feel pro-war yeah we'll hit about to
where'd you read that I baby that's
where the week comes and now I don't
think Fox a bed or MSNBC really uh but
ya know come on you can't find lazy well
and be hey baby you can [__] all over
bill o'reilly [__] he's been great on
this race yet he's been he's the only
guy talking honest out there I love when
people put on their Facebook they show
some cop beating somebody in white
person like that have I just right black
lives matter because it's like hold on
all lives matter yeah did you hear and I
play this on my podcast by the way
what's buggin Oh Nick DiPaolo podcasts
on riot cast dot-com or go to Nick dip
calm and I was talking about the martin
O'Malley he was the former governor of
Maryland he makes he makes Obama look
conservative he's a white far-left
[__] douche in my opinion uh but he
was in front of a black audience and he
goes all lives matter they stop bowing
he's like black lives matter white lies
when he said white lives the all black
white sister booing bow in lit but
here's that his the most important part
of the street the next day he's on a
black radio show apologizing life is
saying all lives matter the libs are
eating each other and I'm enjoying an
hour yeah I they are eating each other
that the [__] psycho st. colleges and
you know time I look what's up yeah I
love in someone will say something with
some liberal or fairness and then some
other famous like or use the wrong words
and then she was no no always making fun
of him and they start fighting am I you
guys are the same side did they rate
each other they're so in a rush to
[__] blame yes well bet that's a good
sign for people like being your
libertarians but they read the political
correctness is time to eat itself alive
i right here in New York de Blasio the
head of the City Council it's her name
she's a Hispanic viverito mark lever
well it but she she she pulled like the
the feminist card the sexist card on on
de Blasio who he works for he she's
she's like you wouldn't it would have
skewered them treating like that if I
was a woman so this done eat each other
and I'm [__] jerking off watching it
jerking off
because nobody likes political
correctness nobody it's just so
restrictive well there's no logic left
people on the far left have lost your
[__] minds I don't give a [__] what
do you decide what's why you say a word
be like whoa whoa whoa how did it get
like that not from righties not from
guys like me I know a the bigots
remember we don't [__] care what we
say can't have it both ways that's how I
feel is a comic he must feel the same
who did a bit about um fake bit about
about mixing his colors with his whites
in the laundry and have them bleed and
then him in the laundromat going these
coloreds these [__] colors let's get
this bit Brian Keith Etheridge but
there's a black I saw in the bathroom
during the setup so he comes out he just
has to go these coloreds yeah his
[__] colors are bleeding all of my
beautiful whites and he goes what the
[__] is this and start suckling but it's
like dude setback nothing's as racist as
you think it is nothing's as homophobic
as you think it is right these things
you're just looking for a reason to be
upset right but all that [__] comes from
the left not the right political
crackers don't come from her that's a
point [__] you that should be said
over and over again I mean they've
bought into a low correctness comes to
the left left is the Liberals yeah
censorship who feminists what do ya what
do you think what feminists now that's
where the political correctness lives
and breathes in in radical feminism oh
my [__] word worse worse than [__]
the race thing to me it's [__] guy
I've been talking about this for year
but I'm just saying uh college campuses
that's a passion of liberalism no
conservative campuses out there they
have speech codes you can't [__] this
safe zones you have to know all this I
do right remember in college I went to a
liberal arts college and university of
maryland growth together no Republicans
on that [__] campus or any other case
some but they were quiet but ever doing
report they were Matthew Shepard just
got just got lynched remember that yeah
or she got beat up tied when everyone
there in vigils and everything and fit
their mold beautiful white kid beautiful
upper middle class that kid and then I
dis report uh and everyone was like I
asked people like how long were you
remember the name Matthew ship like
forever like what you always remember
what why because it's wrong I stand
against what's wrong and then I go
remember the name James Byrd Jr and they
go no who is that am i okay it's a black
guy who got strung up behind a
truck and dragged Ellie was dead just
dragged around like that happen a year
ago like that's the same crime you had
no idea what his name is support but the
Matthew Shepard thing turned out to be a
bit of a hoax I heard no yeah I heard
again you know I don't know what you
what the [__] believe it i read this
i believe either the [__] media no
google it but but it wasn't wasn't a
bunch of [__] rednecks you tied him
one of the guys that beat him was gay or
something no way really thats that again
I don't know this is what I [__] they
want to make things hate crimes even
when it's like no no it was just what
you're bumping into me at the bar I mean
I didn't know you were here and hate
crime again that's a liberal [__] a
liberal [__] concept that somebody
can really you [__] know what's in my
mind when I punch somebody in the face
so in other words under the hate crime
scene you could get in a car accident
yeah you know a fender bender and not
even know the guys gay and like punch
him in the head and then when it comes
out you're [__] right oh you didn't
see his rainbow flag bumper sticker I'm
like no my fender was in it I'm I
suppose have seen driving a yellow Prius
haha you didn't know in a banana runs
tailpipe he couldn't have made it more
clear yeah no it'sit's a mean come on
but but like I said I'm not a [__]
real right when you're either you know
yeah I guess that's what I am too i'm
realizing i'm somewhere in the middle i
think i'm a bleeding heart liberal where
I'm like we gotta take care of some
people leave me alone yeah but at the
same time I'm more anti super liberal
than super super conservative yeah well
I would say the same for me I mean come
on [__] like I said day you know I
don't care the whole gay thing that
doesn't I don't give a [__] then you
know I guy I got peg because Island
jenner is the [__] best what I say
Mike the best way to look at it what
Kate what did I say about her you know
like he was my hero your whole angle is
like we may like that guy is a rudder as
an athlete yeah it was at you I gotta
take down my view but I had his poster
of my bedroom when I was 14 years old
they had to take it down last night
luffy idea but you still have is both
syrup 5353 is low what's a poster
anyways cheap that's a fat head yeah
yeah that [__] doesn't bother me I
actually have a relative that went
through something similar that I
get into details and in a that never
bother me you know i mean but i will
make gay jokes if I think it's gonna
[__] bother you so what do you think
right right don't you do that yeah oh
this is gonna annoy yea RS stable you
some nights at the stand it has a very
Fifi feel to it yeah right if you get
people that I know are hurt by something
I'm like it makes me want to hurt them
more if I'm too dirty and I see people
like to Christian in the audio to Mike
I'm gonna be so real estate in New York
are you for skating with doors my
favorite is when you get the superb
Orthodox Jews come in and they laugh in
the dark [__] they do laughs at the
doctor I've only had a few Orthodox Jews
in the audience [__] love him later
and again I had them as neighbors out in
beverly hills oh yeah I sort of admire
but then I read about him you talk about
sexist and in the right behind the times
with you know women can't do this and
that they are [__] the real aliens
look like in a porter wait about thats
what i wanted to talk to you about maybe
we'll do another next I courage I use
and this is a quote from my boy re here
the libertarian said that Italians are
the lowest form of white people that's
what how long have we been doing this 42
minutes 42 minutes I get let's go five
more okay you gotta go you gotta do this
meeting well stay as long as you can I
gotta be at midtown in [__] 230
that's who thought I want to give you at
least 50 minutes though well how about
this how about this what how about we
get in your car and doing the way up
there and then I'll take the subway back
down can we do that yeah yeah I'll be to
just distracted all right that's so what
I'm a little late a little do I get more
minutes okay it doesn't have to be an
hour right yeah Italians are the worst
of the whites but first of all I'm not
even all Italian you didn't know that
either did you I wasn't thinking about
you night I had to be included what do
you think I'm sweet look at me I'm half
Italian know what happens Canadian in
English Oh on my mother's side so what
what how many Italian kids beat you up
you to come to that conclusion none I
see the way they act you okay let me try
to justify this to you see if I get ya
let me get this straight get you on my
side wait a minute look at this rate
Boston is full of dumb jocks who beat
people up these generalizations
I know but when I do I get labeled I
know this Harvard they're all so I when
I'm aware of that what I'm talking about
that when i do my get labeled a bigot
you do I'm your [__] libertarian get
glasses you gotta mow hanukkah classes
in glasses and a cardigan yeah that's
all oh yeah I did he run nessa ties I
want to get your theory on this they're
always the kind of guys who are gonna
slap on the top of a counter go you want
to come back there I'll come back there
and show you they Revere the most
garbage goes to a black guy or a Puerto
Rican I have a see a black I've ever see
a black guy at a Chinese restaurant that
doesn't get his [__] shrimp okay can
I answer that yeah worst of the whites I
said we're not gluten to the lights I
forgot the premise there you go okay
very clearly delineated but wait a
minute hold on here's my other problem
how the [__] the Italians get thrown
into white snow when i was on televised
okay I agree I'm saying are you every
time I was defending the white point of
view on tough crowd Patrice will Keith
Robinson who are black we go de pollo
you [__] I've even white you're
Italian yeah I guys because they're done
blacks they can't think right I already
said that I didn't know but the day baby
has braces as smart as enemy when you
get a racial like you can't have it both
ways Patrice you can't say I'm [__]
not white and then [__] throw me into
the white category on Columbus Day yeah
when the [__] evil European you if
your celebrated you know saying I'm
saying I do but I see what you saying no
but the only other answer all except
yeah and this is if you classify them
differently is Armenians of Persians but
i'm not sure their whites how about
Albanians they're crazy than in aliens
and they look like italian they're not
as much around they're not enough around
so really how I seek to come to a
conclusion because I saw to see a point
yeah that's all I want sort of thing
left point no but I didn't finish okay
it's it's it's Italians from New York
that setback Italians nationally
absolutely right but all the National
I'm Austin are trying to be that Italian
from New York well that's because the
media you know Tony Manero the 70s yeah
excuse me good fellows we did fellas so
dumb yeah what was your theory exactly
with it that with the lowest form of
white the worst of the whites
not the dumbest but just worst overall
it's gonna be something come on Irish
aunt the Irish definitely in the running
for sure the Irish I thoroughly this is
a sorry the Jewish is coming out
basically saying Gentiles a [__] wit
Gilliam who okay let me ask Allah not go
i'm going with something else but his
dick golems are modeled up like the
monster we created a monster people for
us we made him out of mud and we put the
word are you impressed that i knew that
a very impressive lunder from the
sopranos attention about dom jersey guys
I did there's an episode with a history
his sedum came yeah and and he wanted to
get a get from his wife you get a
divorce or before she wouldn't give it
to him so they came to Tony Soprano oh
yeah remember that one who was you some
can you put some pressure on her yeah
yeah and and and the Sun the Hasidim son
didn't want to get get involved with the
battalion mafia what is clearly Jewish
writer in there and yeah the writers
room going hey guys I got an idea of
Matt why no probably a weiner whatever
his name is a rut brilliant by the way
but that was one of the funniest show
Tony goes you know he gets the guy is
getting the guy didn't want to pay him
what he agreed to Tony goes grabs him by
the folk slaps his hat off his [__]
cityca he goes hey listen to me listen
to me [__] ZZ Top and you wouldn't
want to pay him a Tony calls his friend
hash who is Jewish and he goes Tony
Soprano goes uh hash I'm with my non non
shell non ma the candy shellfish non
shellfish eating friend and he won't
give me the money and hash the Jewish
guy thinks about he goes uh tell you
what give him his brisket [__] but
become a moyel with some [__] thing
in Tony go spray and I dare he hangs up
because get the bolt cutters oh you're
gonna cut the guy's dick hahaha then he
paid him haha that was a good show it
was up that that's funny yeah so I'm re
who's Jewish is telling you the whites
of the Italians in a lowest form of what
do you think not obvious question yep
I'm not gonna say it look what do you
think the best of the whites are the
best of the whites that will be my
brother-in-law rich white and that's his
real name who wants to went to Cornell
and graduated first Morton business
school
the best though I don't know I don't
know what your uh racially got it to
make it down my nationality or something
or like you know subsection of lights
well how many sections a whole lock
Irish you let you see Europe uh is jewel
white I think they put us in white and
if we do if we're the whites than my
feel like I'm Jewish yeah yeah i'd go
with Jewish yeah I've never had a
problem with Jewish people my life we
stick to ourselves like the girls do you
really I don't I'm just I wouldn't I
wouldn't date one a long-term
relationship cuz i heard they were above
that that and I marry they might come
into play but no I was attracted to him
I always thought they were cute and I
never have a problem they've cordial
people and they are smarter they don't
wanna fight they don't want to fight no
I know it something was it like I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I just walk
away and we're generalizing but yes i'm
also the Jewish people I've no I've
never had a problem wit and they are a
lot nicer babe I'm just saying I don't
know you think I'd be doing better and
showbiz with comments like this he likes
Jews everybody nicht Apollo enjoys Jews
well I had that out of him I had that
lot line in my act I used to say well
you know I think the Jews control
Hollywood my friends ago why do you
think that agree we ever read the
credits after a sitcom it's like
Schindler's List some of my best jokes
ever it's my favorite saying especially
in like black movies and then sing all
the Wits ha's and the Berg's and all
that in the lobby as a slave and you say
that 200 Jewish names after what's up
it's made we do run it no you could you
don't we don't you know we've all been
successful at it no you do but what I
don't understand we're not giving each
other jobs well you are so what my point
is if you do run it I mean you said I'm
saying it should be a compliment to run
a business that complex I it's using a
negative about those people bright I
really think you're brighter than most
people that's rather get threatened by
Jon Roy did a joke about that but like
oh jeez love- everybody hates my shoes
love money like who doesn't love who
doesn't money is right yeah you guys
love a little more than us but I know
I'm [__] joke but I bet yeah you know
I used to do jokes like that and it
pissed off my acting teacher Aaron
speiser you're not gonna [__] is your
great comic but taste
doing that horseshit I go [__] you
that's a joke you could have never
thought of it and you know what the joke
ended up on you know what the joke ended
up on uh Matt what's that she was the
show with gay people in the 90 square or
the streaker no no as a sitcom Debra
Messing oh yeah yeah imagine I can't
think of the name of it something and
something yeah supplement what the [__]
is it anyways did my joke ended up in
that really yeah okay and I still think
it was Laura kightlinger she was writing
for the show took it from her but Lars
not a fee I'm not saying that she might
hurt me say it at a table in LA or at
the comedy store it ended up in the
script because they and I done the jump
three is pre previous so was that I was
proud of it will and grace will and
grace there it is Will and Grace
anything they did a joke you know it was
rewritten but when I joke well he's
looking at some he's looking at some
Broadway script and says them about the
you know the credits read like
Schindler's List oh really yeah so
somebody somebody hosts know a I say
Laurie could have been any writer from
will & grace in at The Comedy Store you
know you know steals the most family guy
they don't left and right from comics
yeah I believe it or comics and then
I've heard people from here really make
the same assumptions on our own I think
they come in and they just go let's do
this and it's just like it's just two
dead on over and over again all right
you got a good eye yeah cuz I gotta walk
to my car and [__] get up to it we
did uh 50-something minutes right yeah
sorry let me can i plug my [__]
absolutely man the podcast Nick DiPaolo
podcast at Riot casscom or Nick dip com
which is also where you can get my album
another senseless killing and use a
coupon code Nick for the word radio you
get three bucks off another sense is
killing yes are you talking about you
killing on stage that's the double play
yes why don't I just get that econo my
cousin just a clever title isn't it that
is now when people ask me about it i
said no i'm talking about the lion but
the guide killer was a senseless
I go buddy do I get paid really yeah
I'll take it you get paid doorman I'm
the only guy doing it on monetized
podcast I make some advertising money
here there you'll lose my amazon link
you're gonna teach me how to do it okay
re i'm a big fan brother thanks thanks
for having me on oreos texting and
saying oh feel boston is josh i know you
didn't know it made it I was like I'll
just never tell him that light join up
like i'll see you at the stand
the kill me
Oh
what was it
that is the episode by the time you guys
are hearing this I'll be in know maybe
i'll be on the way to Scotland six hours
what I'll be like right up well maybe
I'll be landing there honestly doesn't
really matter exactly where I am when it
comes out I'll be in Scotland up for the
month I'm excited we'll see what happens
i don't know maybe i'll get into
something maybe i'll fall in love with a
redhead or is that Ireland is that
Ireland what are the Scottish what are
the Scottish like stereotypes ah is that
Scotland um yeah so that's it thank you
guys very much for tuning in I'll be
doing next week's episode from Scotland
I might do a state of the union address
have Dave Smith back on to maybe once a
year or something to get the libertarian
view on the Union and what's going on
with America right now well we'll say
but regardless i'll be doing the intro
from edinburgh scotland or somewhere out
there come to my shows make sure to tell
everybody about my shows this is not
happening it's thursday through sunday
at 11pm at the pleasance dome the ace
ace theatre the ace dome at the Pleasant
stone I think it's almost all booked
Canaan is doing the first week I don't
think we're going to say who the people
are doing which shows but there's
different people doing different shows
Michael che zhan it at some point you
know you don't know how you're gonna get
a lot of European comics that I I just
asked about and you know get get best
case scenario of like I think this guy's
good i haven't really know about mo just
take like referrals and i think we got
some great people so come out eleven
o'clock in n borrow thursday through
sunday every show is different and
you come two weeks in a row and then I
might be the same but all the lineups
are completely different for every
single show so no repeat so if you come
once and it can be the same common again
and if you come in two different weeks
just don't come the same day so if you
come on Thursday one week come Friday
the next week or come thursday friday
saturday sunday one week get four
different shows bam bam boom bomb what
am I going to miss about America the
marijuana which by the way it might be
time for me to sober up a little anyway
if you ever smoked pot all day just I
mean just all day and then it's like so
unbelievably tiring on your brain I
can't concentrate I literally can't
think who I gotta shut my grill thing
off propane lover you just can't
concentrate at all anyway that's what I
did yesterday I mean starting it like
two and going all the way to 22 like 3am
saw that Rousey fight again I don't give
a [__] about female fighting until she
loses one round I don't believe that the
other women are really trained in
fighting until somebody at least tests
her for one right even and it's a silver
lost around a Dan Henderson he didn't
panic cuz he's better than him she
hasn't even impressed like this [__] go
heah lady was like oh she's so tough
like yeah but she's never been punched
in the face once and when she was was it
wait what's this like how do you not
know that yet so until Ronda Rousey gets
tested I just don't give a [__] about
the woman's fight it's just like it's
just one person it's one person who
knows how to fight that's why he's
boring to me
you know I guess she's great but like
how we know were there any huge champion
she took down which she have a rich
franklin that would defended a
championship and then she and then Ronda
Rousey comes in and says no it's like
the organization is made around you you
know it feels almost like something that
you would South Korea or over Vladimir
Putin scored seven goals that are in a
Russian exhibition league game how do I
put the President of Russia that I'm bad
whatever is king of Russia or whatever
he is seven goals in one exhibition game
final she was like 11 to something seven
goals in like three assists and it's
like oh yeah everybody's laying down
it's not quite like that but it's like I
mean they're not laying down the other
girls aren't letting down but there's
not trade it's like it's like if she if
she became a comedian and she joined the
comedian's fighting League and it's like
yes you'd beat us all but it doesn't
mean she's good we're not I love and I'd
[__] on women's MMA and then people go
like oh you don't think she could take
you or like I'm not a fighter that has
nothing to do with it you know you can
say like CC Sabathia is not as good as
he was like he's still better than you
it's like yeah I don't pitch for the
Yankees so I don't have to live up to
those standards anyway whatever by the
way Yankees I know de pollo is a fan six
games up I don't think it's real I think
they'll blow it they don't have a team
this year but [__] it a rod's playing
great couple pitchers are playing great
the relievers are playing great oh
alright you guys it's time to go to
Australia and by that I mean Scotland I
gotta do some podcasts in Scotland or
I'll be [__] i think i have one save
up for next week and then maybe one more
and then one for the week of
tember 11th yeah I'll get some people on
all right ladies gentlemen that's it Ari
Shaffir skeptic episode 2 30 who Danish
inner Neil got to be coming up right on
people get them in October what I film
the next round of this is not happening
you guys if you want to make a
pilgrimage I almost forgot and by the
way use my amazon link re the great com
click on amazon and then go to amazon go
to our the great economically ramazan
takes you to amazon do all your amazon
shopping there and it supports the
podcast and it supports giving the
Kabbalah $100 wait what was there just
going to say was it looking up oh I got
an announcement next week to about my
touring but that that's not for oh I
know I'm looking up when that is not
happening shows are if you want to go to
LA to watch where we are now August
second august third when this comes out
one week to week three week for week
five weeks six weeks seven weeks eight
weeks nine weeks in nine weeks inaba
schneider's birthday and right after avi
Lerner's birthday we have more this is
not happening shows we're recording
they're still happening this tuesday's
is a a week from Tuesday a week from
Tuesday they're still doing in the belly
room the one of the creek in the cave
was great Sal Vulcano is hilarious mark
Normand it's always funny Bonnie
McFarlane everybody was great which boss
Sean Patton who will be doing the TV
show this year you guys know Sean Patton
from doing that story about his friend
coming out in the fake gay bashing then
a real coming out in New Orleans if you
don't know that story look it up on
youtube Sean Patton there's not
happening anyway I believe is what we're
doing October fifth october six and
October twelfth maybe Fitz babe we're
doing more to in that week but anyway
56 12 maybe 11 and 12 that's when we're
doing all the shows so come to LA make
the trip why not stop in see a show The
Comedy Store and then see my taping it
is not happening we'll work out a way to
get tickets for the fan fans when it
gets closer but um but yeah all right
I'm excited we got some good names are
ready you guys got some good names we're
close and some some more one of them a
lot to say the names am I allowed to say
the names well Joey Diaz is one one of
them are let us say the other ones hmm
all right that's it ladies and gentlemen
I'll see you in Scotland Ari Shaffir
skeptic episode 2 30 what did I call
this one on see if I remember because
he's not considered I'm conservative
incorrect I'm conservative in current
and correct he's talked about political
correctness all right which I try to
stay at a subject but he wasn't
conservative it was going to be all
about being conservative I think wasn't
conservative so all right we talked
about some political correctness and uh
huh and how he's not a conservative uh I
get it's not the most focused of
episodes but
they can still be good you know they're
not completely focused who am I talking
to me are you the guys that's it I'll
see you when i'm back in America in
September we'll probably I do it this is
not happening to show in September once
I don't know where I don't know when I
will tweet about it or announce it here
all right bye everybody and if you want
to hear me live you can listen to punch
drunk sports every Tuesday and noon to
two pacific time 12 3 to 5 eastern time
i'll be skyping and with Jason and tivo
& sham Tripoli talking about sports and
so forth and so on this week we'll be
talking about how women's MMA is still
not worth my time okay bye
my pretty country
has been paved on the middle
governor that had no crime
bombs of Ohio
my shopping mall
music billion from seneca took a holga
phones
oh hi
you